tu sais qu'il ya un truc qui marche en
ce moment c'est le cresson alors là non
plus j'ai pas d'opinion sur le christ
c'est ici prédire foot en ex-allemagne
de l'est que cardo un intendant de
l'empereur napoléon 1er découvrir les
premières cressonnière cultivé depuis à
méréville petit village de l'essonne
on cultive le cresson de père en fils
chaque mois sur les bords de la juine on
fait les comptes et depuis la nomination
d'edith cresson à matignon on se frotte
les mains le crid sont souvent mieux les
gens avaient oublié un petit peu le
cresson et en entendant parler d'edith
cresson ont repensé à consommer et
salade un peu particulière aux halles de
rungis depuis que les maraîchers ont
constaté que la vente du cresson avait
progressé de 8 à 10% on ignore la
sinistrose en véritable prénom c'est
gisèle mais depuis de madame cresson est
un gouvernement m'appelle souvent elle
avait dit c'est notre dit elle était
déjà dite du beau monde qu'elles étaient
munis de l'agriculture alors ça a été le
boom est dit que son ouïe ça fait une
propagande pour dire voilà
si la salade de madame edith se vend
bien les produits déshydratés à base de
cresson font mieux encore dans les
grandes surfaces vendent bien mais c'est
sûr que le prêt sont en soupe qui a
nettement progressé cette année puisque
erévan tempe et de stress pour ça la
salade ou une petite salade comme
l'appellent les fourmis japonaise
bénéficie d'une publicité gratuite et
répétitive
or chacun sait que c'est une recette qui
a fait ses preuves c'est une des plus
vieilles figures de la publicité même de
la réclame
on répète on répète on répète et on
espère qu'il y restera une trace c'est
pas très sophistiqué comme procédé mais
c'est très efficace si on a les moyens
effectivement d'avoir assez de
répétition si vous vouliez faire les
mêmes choses en publicité s'agirait tout
simplement de dire par exemple dans dix
secondes de plus créé centre centre
centre centre sont un nombre
suffisamment élevé deux fois pour que la
trace reste c'est ce qui se passe avec
les multiples interventions du premier
ministre ils ont vu que ça dure mais
s'il y a pas de phénomène d'usure le
cresson pourrait bien devenir la botte
secrète du gouvernement
alors le meilleur
cressant depuis qu'est vite et au
gouvernement s de l'info est de l'intox
jacques martin à l'oreille ouais
michail c'est à toi de jouer intox
pourquoi se tient pas debout tu achetais
plus de pression depuis qu'elle est là
moi j'en mange jamais du présent on
s'est séparés aux autres intox intox
allez donc philippe alors à ton avis et
de la trousse et de l'acteur excès
philippe gardella meyzieu oullins club
c'est de l'intox
bientôt tu es si tu sais ce que ça veut
dire intox ça veut dire bonnet d'âne
pour philippe hier
tu as un commentaire à faire pour mon
fils oh oui j'ai un commentaire et je
voudrais vous dire bravo puisque dans
notre désormais célèbre série les intox
de l'info vous venez de piocher dans la
famille cresson et le cresson qui
augmente grâce à edith c'est de l'intox
enfin en principe je m'explique le 29
juillet dernier dans le journal le
parisien paraissait une pleine page avec
pour titre est dit relance le cresson à
méréville hors du mois de mai au mois de
juillet le cresson est en fleurs il est
pratiquement introuvables sur les
marchés de france
donc résumons nous dans la famille
pipeau vous venez de piocher le père et
quel est le métier du père journaliste
bravo u13 qui écoute et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu